and Marvel Comics there are characters
with powers that are so extreme that
they can't be quantified and they can't
be classified Jean Grey is the Phoenix
force had a power that was virtually
unrivaled with the exception of a
handful of people apocalypse is
constantly known as one of the most
powerful earthbound characters Franklin
Richards can alter anything in the known
cosmos he can create galaxies he can
create planets he can bring people back
from the dead and yet quite possibly the
most powerful earthbound character is a
person that can't do any of that instead
his ability is to look at someone like
Franklin Richards and a strip his
ability away to suppress it and turn
Franklin Richards from a God into a non
powered human being what's going on guys
this is rob and today we're going to be
talking about leech
[Music]
so leech is part of a group or a BC was
part of a group called the Morlocks and
we have not gotten into the Morlocks yet
but it is a very interesting story when
you start talking about the the Morlocks
in the Morlock massacre with a mutant
massacre is it's most notably called
that was the actual story arc itself but
we won't go too far into that suffice it
to say when leach was a baby he was born
as a normal-looking human being and as a
toddler his powers manifested and it was
at this point that he really kind of
took on the physical form that you see
now he had three fingers he had green
skin and his parents abandoned him left
him to his fate he was discovered by the
mutant tracker Caliban and Caliban is
himself a mutant and he has the ability
to sense and locate other mutants and
it's for this reason that he actually
becomes pestilence the Horsemen of
apocalypse at a future point in time but
at this point in time he takes Legion
and kind of adopts Legion as a surrogate
father of sorts but really kind of
officially hands them over to a more
human looking woman named Emily and the
reason why I say more human looking is
because the Morlocks are a group of
mutants that live underground and the
reason why they live underground is
because for whatever reason their mutant
power has manifested in such a way that
has also given them for all intents and
purposes a very grotesque physical
appearance or at the very least such a
strange physical appearance that they
simply just can't live with in normal
society when you look at somebody like
Scott Summers despite the fact that he
can shoot optic beams out of his eyes
that can cut mountains in half he can
still wear his ruby coarse glasses and
so he can really still blend in with the
rest of society and he didn't have to
worry about being looked at strange or
funny aside from maybe the color of his
glasses or something like that this
regardless of that though I don't want
to get into a big discussion about Scott
Summers ability to use his powers there
comes a point in time during the mutant
Massacre story arc where mr. sinister
really kind of goes on this campaign to
eliminate the world or at least most of
the world of what he perceives to be
impure mutants this is a group that's
led by gambit once the the Marauders
which is actually whether it was called
infiltrate and kill most all the
Morlocks
Eve that Caliban and leach and maybe a
character named taki Matsuya and I'm I'm
not going to swear that that's correct
but I believe that they survived and I
believe they're rescued by the power
pack which is kind of a younger group of
meetings at the time also a group of
people called the X exterminators which
are they're basically x-factor but
they're in the role of hunting mutants
but we're not going to go too far into
that suffice to say once this takes
place leech kind of goes through a
series of escapades in his life where he
encounters different groups he's a kind
of a friend of the x-men he is enrolled
into a school called st. Simmons which
is a school that takes and normal
students but also takes in mutants and
teaches them what they need to know in
order to really kind of exist in in life
as normal as they possibly can but with
regards to leeches powers himself what's
most interesting about him is that leech
is really kind of the opposite of what
we consider to be the most powerful
characters whenever we look at Marvel
Comics and we look at a character we
determine how powerful that character is
we really kind of create a correlation
where the very least look for a
correlation between their power and the
amount of damage they can do a person
like Galactus who can wipe out entire
solar systems or galaxies is viewed by
us as being astronomically powerful
because of the damage that he can do a
person like Mad Jim Jasper's who's who's
I guess alternate universe or against
one of his alternate universe
incantations warped that universe to
such an extreme degree that the universe
itself had to be eradicated in order to
keep his effects from spilling over into
other universes in the Marvel Comics
multiverse you know we look at these
characters and we say man they can do so
much damage they must be incredibly
powerful but with leech he doesn't
possess those abilities he doesn't have
the ability to alter reality on a cosmic
scale and he does he's not a vector for
the Phoenix force he is someone who
could simply just suppress or negate any
neden power that he comes into contact
with as long as that person
within about 10 meters of a 10 meter
range of him and to me this really kind
of makes him one of the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Comics because
of what use are the abilities to
manipulate reality on a cosmic scale if
you just simply don't have them you know
of what uses Franklin Richards if he
can't use those powers of what uses
apocalypse if he can't use his powers
and when you look at someone like leech
you often see these kind of comparable
circumstances where someone has an
ability but because of the nature of
their ability is the absence of
something else that makes them so
popular or makes them so powerful for
example Iceman there was a time when
Emma Frost took over the physical body
of Iceman of Bobby Drake and pushed his
powers to degrees that he had never
conceived of before that he had never
even dreamed of and she had really kind
of hypothesized that he had the
potential or already was an omega-level
mutant because of his ability to
manipulate the cold and cold is simply
the absence of heat and so the argument
that Emma Frost was effectively making
is that he has the ability to alter the
entire planet by simply removing heat
from a planet itself he could destroy
all life on our planet he could
effectively remove heat from the Sun
assuming that he wasn't obliterated by
it and could destroy the entire solar
system there really weren't very many
limits to what it was that he could do
and so when you look at characters any
Marvel Comics it's important to kind of
recognize that there's a yin and a yang
here there's a balancing act there are
characters with extreme powers that
could effectively destroy our universe
but there are also characters with one
simple power and this one simple power
is so extreme that it really kind of
overrides every other power because it
could have in effect nullify those
powers and take them away from the
person that has them and to me this is
really kind of a great example of like a
game of chess there are people that play
chess and they make the argument that
the best the best offense is a good
defense the best way to play effective
is to simply play it safe the best way
to play effective is to play it smart
and if you had the x-men going into a
battle
if the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants and
leach had somehow found a way to expand
his abilities to a virtually unlimited
distance then of what what challenge
with the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants be
to someone like leach if you could
simply just disable their powers they
would be right for the pickings but it's
really kind of funny here because you
have to be careful what you do with
someone like leech a lot of people look
at the character Franken Rogers and they
asked the question why isn't Franklin
ever part of any major storyline and
Marvel Comics well you I mean the kid
can alter reality on a cosmic scale of
what use would anybody else be in the
storyline
all you have to do is show up kind of
phase the person out of existence and
then that's the end of the comic it'd be
a one page colleague it wouldn't be any
real excitement and there wouldn't be
any real kind of tension or anything
like that for the character like leech
you know the fact that he can nullify
powers again makes him very very
powerful and so you really can't have
him involved that often because you had
had the accident that would go into a
fight and it's going to a fight with
apocalypse ad and then leach would walk
up and leads with nullify apocalypses
powers and apocalypses body would
physically be destroyed by apocalypses
own energies and then that would be the
end of that so it's it's it's really
kind of interesting when you're talking
about characters who have incredible
abilities and then you kind of look at
how they're written in the model comics
because it's a balancing act you've got
to maintain that yin and yang you've got
to take characters who are incredibly
powerful and put them in storylines that
are interesting but not in storylines
where them fighting creates an
improbable scenario at the same time you
know with a character like leech you
have to include him in storylines where
he is interesting where he is intriguing
and you'd like to see him there but not
to the point where everybody else is
involved in virtually becomes nullified
there's really no point for them being
there so with that being said I'm going
to go and ring this video too and hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace